is there any ancient civilization that's
more fascinating than ancient Egypt how
exactly were the pyramids built and how
did ancient Egypt become so advanced in
math geometry engineering and all these
other things what if you lived in
ancient Egypt today unn what if
discussed
[Music]
welcome to what if discussed I'm Richard
Garner and I'm Peter speechin and
Richard the level of fascination around
Egypt and especially ancient Egypt is
well-documented
there's movies documentaries books all
written about it I know kids love
ancient Egypt everybody wants to know
about mummification sure about the
pyramids and who built the fiel Patra
right there so it's it's so fascinating
but it's also so mystical and yeah yeah
for sure yes by design by the Egyptians
maybe I don't know what about being in
ancient Egypt have you ever pictured
yourself living in sort of their day to
day world well it's funny to use the
word mystical because that might be the
explanation for why not know the answer
would be for the most part no up till
leading up to this show no I hadn't
because to your point
there's so much wildly big-picture cool
fast the pyramids and you know the
Sphinx and the Nile and all that
Cleopatra and all this it has this
mystical level of not just reputation
but history that yeah you have I thought
much about the farmer or the the peasant
and what day-to-day life of going to the
market and or planting your cops no I
hadn't and it's interesting because the
archaeology in Egypt that we're so
familiar with is almost exclusively
around the tombs around you know
pyramids etc but we don't know much
about the the life of the everyday
person in a in Egypt mmm-hmm which is
interesting I pictured myself in ancient
Egypt but not necessarily and actually I
pictured myself in in every ancient
civilization but usually not as the
farmer or as the peasant or there's
somebody building the pyramids I was
picturing myself as the Pharaoh or if I
mean if I'm in Greece I'm Socrates or
yes you know if I'm in England I'm
Shakespeare or something so a child be
written so it shall be done one of my
favorite movie quotes speaking of
Pharaoh's and it's interesting because
of all the modern-day movies around
Egypt there was Exodus that was it was
kind of the read the remake or the
reboot of the Ten Commandment story it
wasn't very good there was there's been
the mummy and stuff like that but really
I have to go back to 1956 and
10 commandments which I've probably seen
I don't know hundreds of times it's on
every year it's like I've watched it
zero you've never watched it don't know
what I'm not interested in that sort of
it's a 4-hour Cecily DeMille a typically
exactly why I haven't watched it
Joan Heston is Moses who watches a
Charlton Heston should not be Wow I mean
yes history has not been kind in the
reputation of Charlton has sinned or has
Charlton Heston been kind to the
reputation where our movies don't stand
out no but Yul Brynner to your point
about the Pharaoh it just has this great
line as the Pharaoh and every you know
it says it three or four times
throughout the movie wins big dramatic
moment somebody says something somebody
else so it shall be written so it shall
be done which is interesting because
we'll be talking later to both doctors
Salima Ikram and dr. Bob Brier about how
much this particular society focused on
writing and recording their own history
right yeah pretty interesting yeah let's
get to our first guest
let me introduce her to you combining an
interest in and understanding of the
past with a passion for preserving it
for the future dr. Salima Ikram is one
of the most respected Egyptologists in
the world she fell in love with Egypt
after visiting there with her family as
a nine-year-old dr. Ikram currently
holds the position of distinguished
professor of Egyptology at the American
University in Cairo dr. Ikram is also an
archaeologist an author and a renowned
thought leader on all matters Egypt
appearing in television shows all over
the world dr. Ikram thanks for joining
us thank you very much and we talked a
little bit in your bio about that that
sort of fainted trip as a nine-year-old
girl visiting Egypt and and then falling
in love and obviously it's certainly
informing a lot of the rest of your life
talk about that initial spark and why
just generally people just have this
incredible fascination with ancient
Egypt well I mean I think for everyone
it's a little bit different but I think
one of the things is that it's the art
the images are so compelling and the
buildings are so compelling that people
are sucked
it's beautiful it's strange and
certainly things like the pyramids
they're huge so I think there's a lot of
impact and for many people it's also the
idea that thousands of years ago human
beings without the kind of modern
machinery that we have today were able
to construct such extraordinary
structures and to live very rich lives
leaving behind all of this civilization
art culture literature
um tell us about the hierarchical system
in ancient Egypt it obviously it existed
in a lot of ancient cultures but in
Egypt
how did where you stood in the hierarchy
determine how your life turned out as
far as we know the ancient Egyptians
were fairly hierarchical but that
doesn't mean that they couldn't move
between levels so if you were a Pharaoh
your life would be very different than
if you were a peasant or if you were a
soldier or if you were you know a sailor
so it's just like it is today but
sometimes it was a bit more stringent in
terms of the hierarchical set up yeah no
doubt and like you said it's it's it's
very similar to today and it's very
similar to other ancient cultures
there's been hierarchy forever and it
does dictate your life experience if we
were to talk let's say less Pharaoh and
more let's I don't want to say average
Joe but you know the somebody who would
have been closer to their farmer a
peasant what would what would some of
the day in the life experience be you
know what do you eat where do you kind
of work what do you do for fun those
types of things so I mean again it
depends if you were how rich you were
how poor you were but I think everyone
including the king would live in a mud
brick house if you were a king it was a
bigger house if you were not it would be
a smaller house with less beautiful
decorations so you go off and do your
work people had a variety of things that
they age but it's quite interesting that
the basis of the diet would have been
the same but rich people ate a lot more
meat than poor people so they would have
a lot of lentils and pulses and
vegetables and bread and beer and onions
which were the main stage for the
peasantry sorry just to be clear you did
mention beer there was beer in ancient
Egypt oh yes I mean beer was one of the
main food groups drinking because you
the one sometimes a Nile was not very
clean so beer was the safe thing to do
and that's why everyone drank beer for
breakfast lunch
dinner and a foursome source of wine
that was actually very popular in in
ancient cultures because the water
wasn't always so pure
we've talked a bit about the life of the
people in ancient Egypt but what about
the death of ancient people in ancient
Egypt everyone knows a little about
mummies but you've done a lot of studies
into mummification maybe you can tell us
what exactly was it and why was it so
important to the Egyptians well I mean
some people think the ancient Egyptians
were obsessed by death but that's just
because we've dug up a lot of tombs but
in a way it's they were obsessed by life
and they wanted to live forever and
since they could not sort of freeze
themselves or do anything like that the
next best thing was to mummify
themselves equip their tombs with
everything that they liked best or else
that they couldn't afford that they draw
that on the tomb walls so that when they
would be resurrected because they
believed that after you died you passed
a series of tests and then if you passed
them properly you would live forever in
the fields of yaaru where you have all
the best of whatever the hell it is you
wanted and so to ensure that it was
painted in your tomb and if you were too
poor to have a painter to people through
in a few pots and pans and whatever it
was that they could and your favorite
dishes and they said the word so that
may you have that as an affair a
thousand of beer a thousand all good
things and sometimes they've named them
and then you could just hopefully if it
worked you would wind up with that in
the hereafter forever and ever
sounds like a good deal yeah it sounds
like sort of carries on to this day and
like teenage bedrooms where they've got
posters of things ask there they aspire
to have and I guess in the afterlife
well I'm gonna count on you Peter to
make sure and pack my tomb with a couple
of things that you know are important to
me lots of ESMOD and you mentioned tombs
and of course you know for a lot of
people that those early pictures and
sort of black and white film that came
out of you know Howard Carter and and
and and you know the uncovering of
Tutankhamun and and that really sort of
excited the world partly because the
media was
there now to sort of disseminate those
those those pictures and and to really
sort of lend to the fascination but what
we hear these days is that there's still
a whole bunch more to be found in Egypt
and in fact some people put the
estimates that you know there's still
like 50 percent maybe even 70 percent of
what's to be excavated that still quote
was quote-unquote under the sand if you
were given sort of cart blush and
knowing what you probably know about
what's rumored to be under the sand what
would you want to excavate and why well
there are all sorts of very useful
things that one could try and excavate
because I think it would be nice to do a
city properly or an entire cemetery
properly but what it would also be great
fun to do would be to go and be in
search of can biases army that allegedly
got covered by a sandstorm and was
buried and is somewhere out in the
western desert which would be fabulous
to come upon because then we find out
you know how many people were in the
army how many camels what kind of
equipment they had what they needed in
terms of food and drink for their
expedition but you know they're also
there are many tubes both oil and
non-royal that have yet to be found too
to go in search of that would be also
great fun if you could find them intact
kind of creates an image of like for me
anyways of this sort of the Terracotta
Warriors in you know in China although
those were statues you're talking these
were 10,000 real people from the Persian
army yep real people who went off into
the desert and then they got caught in
the sandstorm so they'd be basically I
do think about them in the same way as
the Terracotta Army because you keep
thinking you'll come upon them and
they'll all be sort of either straight
or else in positions a bit like Pompeii
where you had people frozen in that
snapshot of time but you know and also
it'll be very good to excavate a full
city or even part of the city to see how
people lived and find out you know where
did they go to the bathroom but kind of
rubbish disposals that they have
what kind of cooking that they do well
they were ahead of their time in
advancements as far as we can tell but
what do you think came first their
advancements or their their
understanding of math and geometry and
engineering that led to their better
life or was it their better life that
allowed them to come up with these
Lightspeed advancements chicken-and-egg
but probably at some point they must
have had the idea first
that led to some advancement and after
that they could have once they were more
settled I think once you have a good
agricultural system and you're not
killing each other then there's time to
come up with ideas and improvements and
then you can come up with also you will
come up with social hierarchy and just
general making things a bit more
complicated complex society and culture
because in fact it's sort of when you
have that space and time that people
come up with some excellent ideas yeah
well it's you know it's it's an
interesting and fascinating topic like
we talked about off the top and like you
said there's still so much more to know
so much more to discover so much more to
excavate and a lot of those discoveries
would lead us to having even more
answers as to what that daily life what
it would have been like to live in
ancient Egypt and again we're talking
about even different times in history we
say ancient Egypt but how much time does
that really cover how many thousands of
years are we talking when we're talking
about quote-unquote ancient Egypt and
that's a very good point because
Roenicke trip when Egypt was unified
into one country is 3,000 years until
the Romans came and Cleopatra lost plot
and then the Romans took over so we had
3,000 years of unified Egyptian history
and then before that you have about
2,000 years where there were lots of
city-states or equivalent you know bands
roaming around but you had some sort of
entity in the land that we now call
Egypt in fact Egypt is one of these
probably the only country which has had
an active history
national life we call it that for 5000
years in basically the same geographic
area which is astounding so we talked
about a lot of different things about
Egypt that made them sort of unique and
again you you reference kind of even how
they documented things and in terms of
the pictures the images that sort of
capture people's imagination but the
fact that they documented the way they
did and to the extent that they did
isn't random either and they really
understood the importance of that to the
point even of making education the
reading and writing available to more
than just the elite talk a little bit
about that and how that ended up
manifesting in the advanced societies
that we know of now well I mean we're
still trying to learn more about this
but as far as we know temples had
schools and the each town or even
village had a temple and it wasn't just
the children of the elite who might go
there or have tutors but we think that
often there might have been children
from around village whose parents were
working in the temple and everyone had a
chance pretty much to do that for at
least three to four months a year so
this gave the kids a chance to come in
and learn some basic reading writing
arithmetic and if they showed promise
they could be taken under the wing of
someone and then be advanced and
unfortunately there was a patronage
system so if you found someone who liked
your parents or liked you or thought you
a promise
you really could move up in the ranks so
they're people for example like pat
queen hatshepsut chief architects
architect and master of works the seem
to have come from a very humble
background but yet he wound up being at
the right hand of Queen and creating one
of the most beautiful monuments to
survive from ancient Egypt her temple at
Vero Bahari so um you can see that there
was some degree of social mobility and
what's nice is the ancient Egyptians had
autobiographies in their tombs and like
any autobiography it's not always going
to be a hundred percent true
what enough to see they say well I
started off like this and then I made so
I'm so happy because I work so well and
I got this and then you can see how they
rise through the ranks and sometimes
windup you know being a busier for the
king it shows a pretty sort of I even
say a mature society because for so many
other ancient cultures they used
education and knowledge to prevent
people from rising up through the ranks
Egypt obviously shows embraced it
embracing it probably leads to like you
know advancements in other things right
well tell us about the advancements
because we as we say they were a very
intelligent people
what kind of advancements did they bring
to the world in terms of maybe just in
math or geometry or in science like what
types of things have they brought us
that are maybe still in use today well I
mean certainly I think a lot of the
astronomy that then later on got passed
on to the Greeks and cycle through
because you have a law and medicine a
lot of ancient Egyptian medical
knowledge again got passed through
through the Greeks and on and so a lot
of the you know blood circulation and
things that we think about Galen some of
the ideas were actually from ancient
Egypt and you have to remember the
museum which is basically a mega
University and think tank the first of
its kind was based in Alexandria and
people from all over the world well the
ancient world would come here and study
and then take ideas back and this was a
great melting pot for ideas and it
really has influencing in fact Egyptian
art and architecture also influenced the
Creed's and they write and wrote and
said you know we've learned this from
the Egyptians then they went off and had
a riff on it and then they did something
completely different so when people are
looking at classical Greek columns and
cetera and going on about the Doric
order that was actually born in ancient
Egypt 2,000 years before the Greeks did
anything with it
typical Greek say I think I'm taking
credit for everything democracy it's a
we could go on in
on and it's interesting because I have
it's sort of a different image now of of
this ancient Egypt that you know for a
lot of people ends up being a couple of
pyramids the Sphinx I think we have a
sort of a broader idea of a really
functional interesting society that for
for a time in history actually showed a
lot of like I said sort of maturity in
embracing not a super balanced system
but certainly something that was a
little more than just straight
oppression and hierarchy yeah I mean
there's a there's but again the reason
why we know so much about it today we'd
know more if the Library of Alexandria
wasn't burned down but Peter that's a
story for another well we'll bring you
back for that one because honestly we
could go on forever here and we know
you're busy and you are literally in
Egypt at the American University in
Cairo so thanks for taking the time for
joining us today where can people find
more about your work well I think this
owed God I think there's a web page and
the University web page and I have a
Facebook professional page and I have
seen both of those things and your
websites actually I encourage people to
just Google dr. Salima Ikram anything
coming up in the future I know obviously
the world we're living in is kind of
suspended a lot of the speaking tours
and shows that we're in production what
do you have coming up I'm afraid all of
my speaking tours are on hold but
certainly there are a couple of TV
productions coming up but Tutankhamun
and also about mummification so net
watch out and discovery not you and the
History Channel we'll keep our eyes open
for that again really appreciate you
taking the time today thanks for thank
you so much for joining us dr. Ikram my
pleasure and thank you for the
invitation take care bye-bye great stuff
with dr. kramm obviously like we set off
the top this is a thought leader one of
the foremost Egyptologists in the world
you could even say a genius Pete would
you say policy genius I would say in
Egypt genius but in this case you might
talk about policy geez I'm gonna tell
you a little bit about policy genius you
know with everything going on right now
a lot of people are asking is it even
possible to buy life insurance well what
do you think I would think possibly but
I'm the type of person who doesn't know
the short answer Richard is yes you can
buy life insurance during a pandemic and
if you have loved ones depending on your
income you probably should policy genius
is an insurance marketplace and they're
in contact with the life insurance
companies on their platform every day
keeping track of all the changes in the
market so you don't have to got my
attention which means they can get you
covered quickly and for the best price
here's how it works
policy genius compares quotes from the
top life insurance companies in one
place takes just a few minutes to
compare quotes from the top insurers to
find your best price this doesn't just
save you legwork you know what else is
gonna save you
I'm gonna guess money it's gonna save
you fifteen hundred dollars or more
every year by using policy genius so if
you're one of the many people looking to
buy life insurance right now but you're
not sure where to start
head to policy genius com policy genius
will find you the best rate and handle
the process completely they'll get you
and your family protected and hopefully
give you one less thing to worry about
and who wants more things to worry about
right gosh I've got so many things to
worry about oh I think I think you're
you're not alone no obviously in that
pandemic aside I've got a broken
computer I've got kids out of school a
struggle is real pain my god the
struggle is real but the good news is we
get to talk to people occasionally like
doctor Salima Ikram right and learn cool
things about ancient Egypt which were
both fascinated by and I don't know
about you sort of what your takeaways
were but there was there were things
again you you you think you've sort of
covered it all you've read it all you've
watched documentaries about Egypt you
think you know everything but all of a
sudden you talk to somebody like dr.
Salim a crime and you and you learn
things what did you learn oh my gosh
well first I didn't realize that so much
of Greek culture was stolen from ancient
Egyptian culture and I have a lot of
Greek friends and I leaked Greek living
a Greek art is nothing against the
Greeks but apparently a lot of their
intelligence yes a lot of their
architecture was taken from designs
inspired if you will by Egypt yeah you
could say inspired yeah is it's 3,000
years late
yes which was another thing that really
floored me is that I don't really see
ancient Greece being 3000 years after
mm-hmm ancient Egypt and that speaks to
obviously when we're talking about being
advanced in stuff like math and geometry
and whatever and a line she talked about
astronomy right well what does that mean
well I'm sure you've heard if you've
done even a slight sort of superficial
dig on Egypt that the the three you know
the the Great Pyramid and the three
pyramids are aligned with Orion I mean I
don't know where you start to be able to
have you know going back five thousand
years from now to be able to be like
yeah we know where the oppression of the
equinox is going to be at this
particular time over the course whatever
they obviously knew way more than we
would give people credit for going that
far back and then there were
interactions between ancient Greeks and
ancient Egyptians there was an idea of
understanding and learning from each
other going that far back as well but
the one thing that is clear is that you
know we talked about Greeks you know
democracy and a lot of things even some
of the architectures just talked about
the columns right like we're talking
about
well whatever and then she's like no no
actually that was not stolen inspired
inspired by the ancient Egyptians by the
ancient Egyptian and I wonder if that's
what the Library of Alexandria might
have been adorned with like honestly
like a you know you don't want to sort
of overstate things but if I had the
time machine that every once in a while
we discussed we'd like to have and I
could go anywhere and do anything it
might be to bring a fire extinguisher
too you know whatever happens I don't
know if it's Alexander the Great that is
is credited with burning down the
Library of Alexandria but from from all
accounts there's a whole there's a
myriad of things we would understand
better about the world not just ancient
Egypt but the world if we had access to
all that information it's gone and so is
most of ancient Egypt buried beneath the
sand and we I think you were saying 60
percent well I mean you hear different
ranges but most people agree most
Egyptologists even agree that it's at
least 50 percent interesting that yes
the modern day challenges of money and
budgets and and resources get into why
there hasn't been more excavation in
Egypt but you you can speculate that if
this is what we've dug up
so far right can you imagine what else
is under there yeah because it's not
gonna be just like you know if their
focus is on temples on big stone
structures on big things for the
afterlife with you know these
hieroglyphics and unbelievable things on
the walls those are the things that
stand the test of time
especially if you're talking about being
buried under the sand so they would come
out you don't want to say pristine but
you look at some of the stuff you see in
you know in in Egypt right now it's like
it's it it looks pristine it's it's yeah
you know like these other being aged
doesn't in being aged but I mean when
you're talking five four or five
thousand years before what you can you
can walk up to some of these walls and
read stuff on the walls like it's it's
it's it been well preserved some of it
because it's sort of inside right but I
don't know if you've been to Egypt I've
never been no I'd love to what we could
who could we talk to here about getting
us to Egypt perhaps doing our remote
from Egypt that'd be cool you mentioned
a time machine earlier maybe if we could
invest in one of those that might be
good for the show to have a time machine
I think we could visit many different
places and that is a story that's a
story for another what if but one other
thing that that dr. Ikram mentioned was
the soldiers yes the the procession of
soldiers and they're just lost
underneath the sand so and you know the
terracotta warrior thing was a good
reference which is also interestingly
enough in that series with Brendan
Fraser mommy and then it's the yeah I
didn't see that I didn't see national
treasure I guess you didn't do it I like
to Indiana Jones yeah temple to do well
he gets to Egypt right and at some point
and obviously the you know the talk of
the Terracotta Warriors is is
interesting because you see these sort
of statues but this is supposed to be
this is people this was this was you
know obviously a sort of a brigade of
soldiers Persian soldiers coming towards
Egypt perhaps this is a divine
intervention by the the sun-god rah or
however it would have been seen by
ancient Egyptians that they were somehow
saved by an a you know a fortuitous
sandstorm that apparently but this is it
sounds like one of those those next
great sort of archaeological challenges
is finding finding the exact location
first of all which is probably
challenging but to be able to dig up and
see what you could learn
by discovering that but again it's it
sounds like there's just there's we got
a lot of answers today we got a lot of
insights but it's it for me it's almost
there's no more questions than answers
because I'm more curious about what it
is that we don't know versus what it is
that we do yeah
there's a lot we don't know and there's
a lot you can find out because if you
enjoyed this episode let's carry on the
conversation let's spend more time with
the topic click on the description click
on the link in the description below and
that will take you to the extended audio
version of the podcast of dr. Bob Bryar
will join us one of the world's foremost
experts on mummies and Egyptology so on
behalf of Richard garner and myself
Peter snitching thanks very much for
joining us we'll see you again on what
if discussed
[Music]